also ich glaube das große problem ist
heute dass die lebensmittel und
betriebskosten preise so auf die
familien und auf die menschen drücken
und das nicht nur auf die armen familien
die wir haben sondern die neuen die
hinzu kommen die mittelschicht und ich
spreche nicht von unternehmen mit 1000
mitarbeitern sondern ich rede da
tatsächlich von betrieben die 315
mitarbeiter haben die ist einfach nicht
mehr schaffen die dann in armut beraten
und die dann zu den tafeln gehen weil
sie da eventuell günstige lebensmittel
bekommen die bekommen sie nicht weil
viele konzerne viele
lebensmittelgeschäfte kaufen gar nicht
mehr so viel ein weil sie wissen die
menschen habe ich mir so viel geld in
der tasche kaufen nicht so viel also
wird auch nicht mehr so viel weggeworfen
also bleibt bei den tafeln nicht mehr so
viel übrig und immer mehr menschen
kommen auch zu uns wir haben ein boom
von familien die kommen die lange
gewartet haben gesagt habe wir schämen
uns wir geben uns vermutlich zu und
jetzt kommen sie nicht mehr klar und wir
haben die probleme dann dass das erst
mal auf die psyche der menschen wirkt
wir haben viele alleinerziehende mütter
die angst vor obdachlosigkeit haben wenn
die betriebskosten abrechnung kommen die
kommt zum ende des jahres aber
allerdings für 2021 2022 kommen sie für
22 das heißt wir verlagern ja auch noch
mal ein problem das wir mit ins nächste
jahr schleppen und wir haben viele
kinder die werden in zukunft und
gefrühstückt in die schulen gehen weil
das geld nicht mehr da ist die kinder
gesund zu ernähren wir haben jetzt eine
hartz 4 satz da bekommt ein kind drei
euro 50 pro tag für lebensmittel für
essen was ihn zur verfügung steht davon
kriegt man heute kein kind mehr satt und
dann wenn eine mutter ist noch gut
meinte gibt sie ihrem kind die tüte
chips damit sat wird das ist realität in
vielen familien in deutschland und diese
kinder können sich im unterricht
konzentrieren die sind sowieso abgehängt
schon durch corona wir haben kinder die
wahren 2020 in der schule besser als
heute das schulsystem ist nicht
nachgekommen und wenn wir heute eine
vierte und fünfte welle hätten wir die
schulen zu machen würden dann hätten wir
nichts gelernt aus der vergangenheit
oder die kinder sind immer die dummen
sie sind immer die leidtragenden und es
war schon früher so dass kinder ein
unkalkulierbares armutsrisiko sind und
das hat auch diese regierung immer noch
nicht kapiert wir haben kinder diese
nicht die zukunft der gesellschafter
sondern sie sind die gegenwart und ich
kann nicht mit einem bürgergeld oder mit
unterstützung für familien warten zum
nächsten halben jahr sondern ich muss
etwas tun und deswegen ist mein
vorschlag die
mehrwertsteuer auf die lebensmittel bis
zum jahresende abzuschaffen damit die
bevölkerung sich erholen kann denn die
haben und das haben sie gerade richtig
gesagt diese düsteren nachrichten hören
wir natürlich aus den medien hören wir
von den politikern ihren willen im
klassenzimmer agieren wir überall die
drückt auf die psyche der menschen sie
können nichts mehr hören sie haben keine
positive motivation mehr das was wir tun
in unserer einrichtung hauptsächlich ist
die menschen zu motivieren sie zu
unterstützen moralisch beizustehen und
ihnen zu sagen wir stehen an der seite
und wir schaffen das gemeinsam wir haben
heute in der politik ein großer vorwurf
ist dass keiner mehr sagt offen zugibt
wir haben ein riesenproblem das können
wir nicht alleine lösen wir brauchen
vorschläge aus der bevölkerung warum
greift man nicht auf das potenzial von
82 millionen menschen zurück und sagt
wir können auch mal auf die experten
hören wir haben in vielen politischen
gremien menschen sitzen die haben gar
keine ahnung die sitzen und können gut
politik aber sie haben nichts mit dem
menschen zu tun an der basis hessische
kommune frage zu ihrer forderung mit der
mehrwertsteuer und damit auf die
lebensmittel es gab ja mein england ein
experiment wo beispielsweise gemüse
billiger gemacht wurde der mitglieder
zugreifen es hat leider nicht
funktioniert die studien haben gezeigt
dass die menschen trotzdem dann zu den
chips gegriffen haben
was könnte man vielleicht noch tun um
auch dem zu entgehen dass kinder auch
wenn sie aus vielleicht aus familien
sind die auch nicht dafür sorgen können
für gutes essen könnte die politik
vielleicht mehr organisationen wie ihre
unterstützen es gibt es noch für wege
also ich voller seit jahren dass das
geld beim kind ankommt das ist ja das
problem an stopft dann häufig in den
familien löchern und sagt ich gebe jetzt
mal geld in die familie das geld kommt
beim kind nicht haben weil der
kühlschrank kaputt gegangen ist oder
viele sagen die rauchen und versaufen
das geld das stimmt ja überhaupt nicht
dann hätten wir bei über 3 millionen
kindern eltern die alkoholiker wären
hätten wir noch ganz anderes soziales
problem das geld kommt bei den kindern
häufig nicht erkannt es bei den kindern
ganz einfach man kann heute alles mit
regeln die kinder können bezahlen über
ihrem smartphone mit einer app und das
geld wird nicht bei den eltern abgebucht
sondern beim jobcenter wir haben es
wurde mal überlegt als frau von der
leyen familienministerin war eine
chipkarte heraus zu bringen wo kinder
sozusagen das geld fürs schulessen drauf
bekommen und so weiter und ich war
damals
europäischer botschafter fürs gegen
armut und ausgrenzung und habe gesagt
ist jedoch sinnvoll wenn man nicht nur
für arme kinder seine chipkarte hätte
sondern für alle kinder bei den einen
laden die eltern das auf und bei den
anderen witz das jobcenter auf und es
gibt keine diskriminierung und wenn man
so eine app hätte seine bezahl app wo
die kinder zum beispiel ihre nachhilfe
bezahlen lassen könnten oder wie auch
immer dann würde das geld direkt beim
kind ankommen das passiert aber nicht
und deswegen ist die herausforderung die
viele familien haben groß und die
kinderarmut wächst ins unermessliche
herr braun was halten sie von den
vorschlägen von hamilton wir haben jetzt
zwei themen miteinander vermischt die
wir glaube ich noch mal sortieren müssen
weil an der ersten stelle ist eine
situation beschrieben worden die glaube
ich sehr bedrückend ist also die
situation die viele menschen erlebt
haben gerade die kurve 19 pandemie und
die einschränkungen die es dort gab an
dass fast glaube ich auch zum überlaufen
gebracht und deshalb halte ich es für
sehr wichtig hier auch nochmal
herauszustellen wir haben jetzt wieder
neues infektionsschutzgesetz dass die
maßen haben dazu geführt dass muss man
schon
ein eher brauchen wir sind schon weiter
wir sind im themenkomplex schon
besiegelt ich glaube auch ihnen wird
doch jetzt mehr die armut der menschen
am herzen als infektionsschutzgesetz und
jetzt vermutlich würde noch von ihnen
folgen die rolle von der buschmann und
herr lauterbach und das zusammenspiel
oder das wichtig ist dass wir nicht noch
einmal in einem lokal reinkommen das
betriebsschließungen möchte die fdp
dafür gefeiert werden das ist über zwei
jahre nach der pandemie mal begriffen
hat keine locker und ich glaube wir sind
da schon auf kurs gewesen aber wenn sie
die situation verfolgen die diskussions
und neues infektionsschutzgesetz den
vorschlag den karl lauterbach gemacht
hat und das was jetzt beschlossen wurde
auf dem weg hat sich doch ein ganzes
stück verändert und ich glaube nicht
dass das beitrag der spd waren sondern
das war unter anderem marco buschmann
der dafür gesorgt hat dass gerade kinder
wird vermutlich wieder möglich sein ach
ja fünfter klasse das wurde nicht
ausgeschlossen dass hat ihrer op
zugelassen werden wir uns mit anderen
ländern vergleicht nicht will dass fast
gar nicht aufmachen aber ich würde jetzt
nicht als fdp-politiker da eine große
logistische erwarten von der bevölkerung
meiner sicht ist es ein erfolg bei
vielen der betriebsschließung locker und
das sind sehr sehr harte sehr
einschneidende maßnahmen die gibt es
eben nicht und es stimmt es ist
vereinbart worden sind die länder dafür
zuständig das sollte es noch mal
erforderlich sein dass wir in eine
situation kommen die sehr bedrohlich ist
wo der präsenzunterricht nicht mehr
stattfinden kann dann kann so eine
maßnahme verhängt werden die sehe ich
aber im moment nicht da sind jetzt die
länder aber auch ein verantwortungs
fraglich ist das was diese dieses neue
woher lauterbach sagt und ganz stolz
darauf ist wir haben das strengste
europäische
infektionsschutzgesetz und es ist
furchtbar dieses so viel schneller als
es ganz schrecklich es ist auch nicht
wahr dass es die pandemie ist die den
kindern und jugendlichen zu zugesetzt
hat es sind die maßnahmen die anderen
europäischen länder blicken wo die pan
ja schon für beendet gerade feiert sich
hier eine deutsche leute was ich ganz
durchgreifen so ist oder das ist schlimm
das sehen wir auch in den familien und
bei den patienten dass sie sagen das
hört ja überhaupt nicht mehr auf wir
haben gedacht jetzt ist es vorbei mit
diesem ganzen masken gedöns mit dem dass
wir immer wieder uns testen müssen dass
wir unsere kinder damit gequält haben
und dass wir noch irgendwann noch mal
irgendwie freut uns kaum kommt noch
irgend ein virus um die ecke haben wir
dann das nächste drama nein auf gar
keinen fall also ganz klar gesagt nicht
die pandemie hat das drama bei den
kindern jugendlichen und erwachsenen
verursacht die maßnahmen waren es und
dass sie nicht
berechtigt waren hat sich an
verschiedensten stellen gezeigt es hat
sich gezeigt dass die dass viele länder
besser oder gleich durchgekommen sind
wie wir die wir die heutige united sich
psyche gemacht darüber sprechen wer
gleich noch nie ich würde gerne einmal
nochmal hervor anhalt abholen zu der
thematik von hälftige kann auch zur
segelkurs vorschlägen es ist der politik
ja nie so richtig gelungen die
kinderarmut zu bekämpfen oder sie ist er
gewachsen in den letzten 20 jahren ist
die armut zahl der kinder verdreifacht
worden seitdem erst ein armutsbericht
und die geburten zurückgegangen also die
politik hat nicht viel erreichen dem
thema genau und es hat auch keine partei
bis heute zugegeben wir haben
kinderarmut sie haben nur angefangen
irgendwelche gesetze zu verabschieden
oder irgendwelche sachen zu machen aber
keiner hat deutlich gesagt wir haben in
deutschland genau mut habe ich noch
keine fahrzeuge also dienen den
vorschlag die lebensmittel für die
lebensmittel den den mehrwertsteuersatz
zu senken in einer solchen situation wo
wir von zwei seiten in die zange
genommen werden das ist einmal die
inflation und auf der anderen seite
exorbitant steigende energiepreise die
auf dem weg der steuererleichterungen
natürlich viel besser zu bewegen werden
als wenn man jetzt sozusagen versucht
immer zu verteilen möchten dem man immer
noch mal versucht irgendwo und die
wissen sie werden es nie
wirklich adäquat ihm bekommen dass er
gerecht zu gestalten
das wäre einfacher gewesen wären
übrigens auch der bessere weg gewesen
bei dem beim beim benzin hat man gesehen
hat dass jetzt benzin preise explodieren
da hat man dann gesagt jetzt wird das
irgendwie von staatswegen einmal sagen
können wir setzen man ihm den den co2
preis aus oder den mehrheits steller
preis für eine gewisse zeit aus bis die
leute sich dran gewöhnen können und und
wir die vielleicht dann doch die krise
bewältigt haben ich verstehe das nicht
aber ich weiß auch woran das liegt also
beim benzin war es klar die grünen
wollten unbedingt den hohen preis haben
da wollten sie eben nicht mit der steuer
hatten sich ja gerade durchgesetzt dass
nochmal co2 steuer das benzin teurer
macht
es ist immer eine partei politik die die
da war eine rolle spielt und natürlich
finde ich ganz schlimm wenn wir
feststellen also mich macht das ganz
betroffen was sie sagen weil ich habe ja
auch das gefühl
dass auf dem thema auf dem ich zu hause
bin in der klimapolitik genauso
argumentiert wird ja wir machen einer
ganzen generation angst vor dem
armageddon dass sie sich an kleben auf
den straßen die glauben ja wirklich die
welt geht unter wir haben das ja hier
tür geheimer thematisieren aktivist war
ja hier nicht allerdings dann
hinterlässt man gefahren erst dann mit
dem taxi nach hause gefahren aber es ist
dann tatsächlich so dass die das
wirklich glauben und da haben wir da
haben sie denn eigentlich angesprochenen
klimaschützer sie jetzt hier die es bei
nehmen und er dass das taxi das urbane
dass ich habe ja keinen ärger haben und
weiß ja nicht was man
aber ich würde aber das größte problem
ist dass man niemals die kinder gefragt
hat wären weder bei corona noch heute es
kommen immer nur mal gesprächen darüber
dass familien sich zu wort meldet melden
sich politiker zu wort aber er fragt
aber die kinder wie geht's dir was hast
du für den vorschlag oder wie gehst du
damit um das passiert nicht da ist
keiner dabei den kindern selbst der
lehrer der ist ja natürlich auch
überfordert mit mit seinen kindern weil
er eben auch unser schulsystem lässt
sehr zu wünschen übrig aber die kinder
sind während corona und anderen themen
nie zu wort gekommen und die wir kommen
immer noch nicht zu wort und sie sind ja
in letzter instanz die leidtragenden